today on the matt walsh show the cop who
killed ashley babbitt has gone public he
was interviewed by nbc and after seeing
him and listening to his side i am even
more sure than i was before
that uh her killing was unjustified she
was murdered also president biden
literally falls apart on camera while
responding to the terrorist killing of
13 american servicemen and the supreme
court shuts down biden's
unconstitutional eviction moratorium
unsurprisingly plus the media is lying
about covet and florida again and in our
daily cancellation we'll deal with the
new
non-binary remix of its reigning men a
very important issue and one of many
that we will discuss today on the matt
walsh show
so last night uh finally more than a
half a year after the unarmed ashley
babbitt was shot by a capitol police
officer
in the capitol building the name of the
shooter was made public
and not because it was officially
released by anybody in a position of
authority as has happened in every other
controversial police shooting in recent
memory
they would have been fined just letting
his name never make it officially into
the public even though had been
circulating online for some time now in
this case uh it was because the officer
himself michael byrd is his name
decided to speak out
fortunately for lieutenant michael byrd
who shot ashley babbitt in the chest at
near point-blank range as she was
climbing through a broken door he was
able to face the public with the help of
a very powerful pr team otherwise known
as the entire mainstream media doesn't
even have to pay them pay pay them it's
a pretty sweet deal
lester holt of nbc news sat down with
bird to
pitch him softballs and give him a
chance to extol his own virtue and
courage which he was more than willing
and eager to do
early on in the exchange in fact
bird declared that he showed quote the
utmost courage in reference to himself
by shooting an unarmed woman in the
chest
listen to this can you give us the
nature of some of those threats
they
talked about you know killing me
cutting off my head
you know very vicious and cruel
things racist things
there were some racist attacks as well
it's all disheartening because i know i
was doing my job given the nature of the
threats that you described do you have
any concern about showing your face and
identifying of course i do
that is a very vital point
and it's something that
is frightening i believe i show the
utmost courage on january 6 and it's
time for me to do that now oh i'm sorry
he actually credits himself with courage
twice so he has the utmost courage on
january 6 by shooting an unarmed woman
in the chest he also has the utmost
courage just by sitting down in front of
a friendly media who is ready to
celebrate him and accept everything that
he says there's a lot of courage there
as well now what led into that is he was
being asked about um the threats
the response he's gotten after his name
leaked on on social media and he claimed
that he's getting all these threats
people threatening to cut off his head
he claims he claims anyway
and you see how lester halt there again
part of the pr team leading him coaching
him along like racist threats was the
racist threats too
oh yeah sure oh yeah racism also
we haven't seen any of that we have no
evidence of it but that's what he tells
us
at least nobody can accuse him of having
an over over abundance of humility at
least
and byrd then goes on to explain uh what
led up to him deciding to pull the
trigger on that day he does claim
he claims that he issued repeated
warnings
and that's one really important part of
this did he say anything did he issue
any warnings before firing his weapon
uh he says that he did
but that's not substantiated by any
video that we've ever been allowed to
see
or any witnesses that we've heard from
it seems like you probably could
substantiate that
i'm sure on the other side of that door
there's some security footage security
cameras all in that building
you might be able to hear some of that
but we haven't we haven't they haven't
released that to us
we haven't heard from any witness who
says that they heard him yelling and
giving a warning but he says that he did
and we'll listen to that part here
he says officers barricaded the door
what he considered the last line of
defense i had been yelling and screaming
as loud as i was please stop get back
get back stop we had our weapons drawn
bird only his hand and gun visible
targeted a figure trying to climb
through a window
he fired a single fatal shot hitting
ashley babbitt she was 35 years old an
air force veteran trump supporter and q
on follower i was
taking a tactical stance you're
ultimately hoping that your commands
will be complied with
and unfortunately they were not when you
fired
what could you see
where were you aiming you're taught to
aim for center mass
the subject was sideways
and i could not see her full motion of
her hands or anything
um
so
i guess her movement
you know
caused
the discharge to
to fall where it did and what did you
think this individual was doing at that
at that well she was posing a threat
to united states house of
representatives
now you note there how they also
included the bit about how she was a a q
anon follower
not sure what that has to do with
anything now we're told that
um george floyd
being a violent felon
who uh
rushed into a woman's home and put a gun
to her stomach and robbed her in front
of her kids that that history
those biographical details about george
floyd are not relevant at all in fact if
you bring them up you're a horrible
person you're a racist even somehow for
simply bringing that up it's got nothing
to do with anything we're told
and yet the fact that ashley babbitt
believed in some kooky
uh q anon thing what does that have to
do with anything
did he know that
does that we're always told about george
floyd well yeah he might have done all
these horrible things and been this
violent uh terrible
scumbag of a person but but the officer
didn't know that didn't know that
that doesn't get him off the hook
well what did what information about
ashley babbitt
did michael byrd have
none
now this leads us to perhaps the most
revealing point in the interview holt
asks him if the fact that he didn't know
whether she was armed altered his
decision-making at all
and listen to his answer because it's
very important here
her family points out that she was not
armed
that's correct the fact that you weren't
aware whether she was armed or not did
that alter the decision-making
it did not what should we make of the
fact that there were other officers in
other
potentially life-threatening situations
who didn't use their service weapons
that day
i'm sure it was a terrifying situation i
can only control
my reaction my training my level
expertise that would be upon them to
speak for themselves
former president trump has has talked
about you and this and this incident
he says she was murdered
what does it
feel like to hear that from a former
president well it's disheartening if he
was in the room or anywhere
and i'm responsible for him
i was prepared to do the same thing for
him and his family
what does it feel like what does it feel
like to be to be
to be called a murderer
yeah what does it feel like well it must
not feel great
can we get that question to all of all
of the other cops
in every single shooting that the blm's
been upset about they've all been called
murderers
from the very top
what about the copy shot mikaya bryant
saving someone's life in the process
saving the life of a young black woman
by shooting someone who's trying to stab
her to death
some crazed lunatic with a butcher knife
he was called a murderer
by many many very prominent people
including in the white house if i
remember correctly
can we sit down with him say how does
that make you feel
when you were when you were directly
saving someone's life and you were
called you were accused of racist murder
now that question doesn't ask we only
ask it of of this guy here
now on the on the topic of whether or
not she was armed notice what what
uh officer byrd does not say
he does not say
that he thought she was armed
he doesn't say that he couldn't see her
hands and thought maybe there was a gun
he doesn't say
that he thought she had a bomb in her
backpack or something
he says that he wasn't sure if she was
armed or not and he shot anyway that's
what he just said
now i want you to imagine any other
police officer from any other shooting
in memory
offering a justification like that
well did you think he was armed i didn't
really know
but you shot him yeah
what kind of reception do you think that
would receive
and we'll return to that point in a
moment but let's wrap up with one more
clip holt uh briefly puts bird in a
mildly uncomfortable position by asking
him about an incident a few years ago
where byrd left his loaded service
weapon in a bathroom
and walked away clearly demonstrating
you would think a certain uh
recklessness that may have played a role
in what transpired on january 6 but byrd
simply shrugs that off and says that it
was a mistake and it was dealt with and
holt doesn't push him on it then at the
end bird who has already bragged of his
incredible
steadfast courage
makes this claim let's listen
multiple investigations have now upheld
byrd's actions on january 6th
capitol police in their
press release after exonerating you said
your actions potentially save members
and staff from serious injury and
possible death
what was it like to hear those words to
see those words
those words meant a lot because that's
exactly what i did
on that day
that was my mission
that was what i
prepared for
and
it's
rewarding and refreshing to hear that
oh i'm glad you're rewarded and
refreshed this is grotesque it's just
disgusting you you think you can't be
any more
uh disgusted by the media but then they
they manage to stoop to new lows every
single day
he killed a woman and the whole
interview is about how he how does that
make you feel how does it make you must
make you feel good to hear to hear that
the capitol police did an investigation
of themselves and discovered that they
themselves hadn't done anything wrong
well that settles that i suppose
in fact he's quoted michael bird is
quoted by nbc news as these aren't the
words you hear in that in that clip but
they quote him
in their article um
that is him saying that he saved quote
countless lives
countless lives
he's not even saying
that he thought he was saving lives at
the time
that would be one thing
he's saying that even now looking back
on it in hindsight he did save all of
those lives
i mean how
we know that ashley babbitt we know now
some of this he might not have known at
the time but now we know that ashley
babbitt was a five foot two inch unarmed
female
and even now he's saying by killing her
he saved countless lives what was she
gonna do
was she gonna bust through the window
and murder dozens of armed cops with her
bare hands
was she uma thurman and kill bill some
kind of trained assassin
the claim from bird is absurd on its
face the whole interview was absurd
again grotesque
and impossible to imagine any other
police officer ever receiving that kind
of treatment or being given this sort of
opportunity by nbc or any other media
outlet at all
and that's one important point to be
made about this of course before we talk
about whether babbitt's shooting was
justified based on the objective facts
of the case it is inarguable that the
people defending it every single one of
them would be exploding with outrage if
she had a different skin color and a
different political affiliation all of
these defund the police champions have
finally discovered one unarmed shooting
of a civilian that they support which
only proves what we already knew
that all of their concern over police
brutality really has nothing to do with
police brutality at all
and i have and i am not aware i don't
think it's an exaggeration to say that
none of these people have
come to the defense of ashley babbitt
not a single one
that pro
and they believe by their own
professions that police officers are
many of them serial killers basically
they they only get into this line of
work because they want to bully and kill
people and be oppressors that's what
they say
and and normally when there's a shooting
of a of a civilian
and the person is unarmed
right that's all that's all the
information they need they were unarmed
and period you don't kill them
we have been told this so many times
and yet in this case it's not even that
they look the other way they celebrate
it
they don't care about police brutality
they don't care about abuses by the
state they don't care about anything or
anyone they don't even care about the
dead criminals whose faces they paint in
murals on walls it's only about the
ideology the dead bodies are vehicles
for their ideological agenda
now they'll deny this of course and say
that somehow this is different ashley
babbitt was in a government building
they'll say she was trespassing she was
warned allegedly
but almost all of the blm martyrs were
also warned repeatedly to stop and they
didn't george floyd was warned jacob
blake was warned ray shard brooks was
worn they were all warned
michael brown was certainly warned
and as far as government buildings if
that somehow makes all the difference
and i don't see why it should
i mean is there something sacred about a
government building
if they've been doing this in a in some
sort of private building with that that
that changes things why
are the lives of uh of congressmen and
politicians are they are they actually
more important than the lives of just
regular people is that what you're
saying apparently that's that's what
we're being
told if that does make all the
difference well blm militants invaded a
police station and burned it to the
ground
with cops fleeing for their lives they
assaulted a federal courthouse for
months on end if any cop had fired a
single shot at any of them and they
didn't not one shot fired
through all of those months
but if they had
there would have been eruptions of
outrage
blm would have burned cities to the
ground in response even more cities
anyway
so we know that that
is the case with with these people we
know that that's the the
hypocrisy here and it actually is
hypocrisy in this case that's an
appropriate use of the term because a
hypocrite is someone who pretends to
believe something pretends to hold a
conviction or principle that they don't
actually hold
and that describes blm and defund the
police to a t
but just looking at the objective facts
on the ground the objective facts of the
case
was can we say with everything that we
know now there's still a lot that we're
not being told there's still a lot of
evidence that we're not being allowed to
see a lot of footage that we're not
being given many supposed eyewitnesses
that we've never heard from
but based on everything that we know and
have seen can we can we say that ashley
babbitt shooting was justified and i
would say even more now that i don't see
how that could possibly be the case
and i think there are a few points
a few things that point to that and many
of them were touched on in the interview
but they weren't they didn't dwell on it
they just moved on one of them
is that there were a whole lot of cops
there that day and not a single other
one of other cop felt the need to fire
their weapon
i think that really tells you something
he was the only one and he claims he
saved countless lives
if he needed to fire a shot to save
countless lives
then then countless lives should have
been should have been taken elsewhere
because all these other cops weren't
firing any shots
so that doesn't make a lot of sense
we also know that that ashley babbitt
was surrounded
by armed police officers
behind her coming up the steps
uh with with rifles and and uh
and on the other side of that door he
wasn't the only one in that in that
hallway you can even see that on the
clip
did he need did he have to resort to
lethal force
in order to stop her when she is an
unarmed woman
surrounded by police officers with their
guns trained on her
i don't see how that could possibly be
the case
could he not have run up as she was
climbing through the door and pulled her
down
and put her in cuffs and detained her
could he not have easily done
that um
if he had said something like
well i thought she had a gun i thought i
saw one
yeah then it would just be a matter of
do we believe the claim that he actually
thought he saw a gun and there'd be no
way for us to know we don't really know
we can't be inside his head in the
moment
but he's not even saying that he's not
even saying i thought she had a gun
he is saying i didn't know
and that to me is the final fact that
really settles it
she was murdered and it's more clear
than it ever was before
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
now let's talk about blue blocks you
know i spend like so many of you
much of my day staring at screens and
probably the main
uh downside of staring at screens all
day is that it just eats away at my soul
and it plunges me down into the depths
of utter despair from which i cannot
ever emotionally escape but the second
worst thing about it is all the blue
light which damages your eyes it can
lead to blurred vision headaches and dry
watery eyes blue blocks was created to
fix this problem of the eyes not the
despair and the eating of your soul and
block out the damaging blue light with
high quality lenses unlike other types
of blue light glasses blue blocks are
evidence-based and made under optics
laboratory conditions in australia the
founders were unhappy with the quality
and lack of science behind leading blue
light blocking glasses brands and that's
why blue blocks exist blue blocks was
created to change this uh with high
quality lenses for daytime night time
and for uh color therapy exactly in line
with the suggested peer-reviewed
academic literature they have over 40
stylish frames for every need they come
in prescription non-prescription and
reader so you got to take advantage of
this go to blueblocks.com
walsh and use coupon code walsh to say
15 that's blueblocks.com
o x dot b-l-u-b-l-o-x.com slash walsh
and use coupon code welsh for 15 off
all right so let's go uh first from fox
the latest from afghanistan says a day
after two suicide bombings hit the uh
kabul airport the death toll in
afghanistan has risen to more than 100
people thursday's bombing
near the airport killed at least 95
afghans and now we know 13 u.s troops
have been killed as well in the
deadliest day for u.s forces in
afghanistan since august 2011
late thursday u.s defense department
officials said the death toll for uh u.s
service members remained at 10
but the count included 10 marines and
two army soldiers instead of the
previously
reported 12 marines and then um there
was also one member of the navy was also
killed
and then that's on top of a
hundred additional people
and i think we could expect at least
that part of the death toll to rise
you know
uh we're gonna play i go we'll play some
clips from joe biden's press conference
yesterday
and we talked about this on backstage
last night and if you watch the press
conference it was
it was
in many ways one of the most disturbing
presidential addresses that
i would say in fact the most disturbing
one that i've ever seen in my lifetime
given the
context
given what he is responding to
to see this old frail confused man
just
collapsing on camera
was extremely disturbing
and it doesn't give you a lot of
confidence
that we're gonna get out of this
situation and when i look at this you
know one of the big questions that i
have is um
and you know as i've been saying for the
last couple of weeks
and like we debated very passionately
and furiously on backstage last night
which is really interesting conversation
by the way if you have if you didn't
watch that episode you should go back
and watch it
uh it's on you can watch it on youtube
or dailywire.com
but i i still maintain that leaving
afghanistan is the right thing to do
uh it's been handled in the most
incompetent way imaginable
and
a number of very obvious mistakes like
shutting the air force base down very
obvious mistakes have been made
leading to this situation where now you
we had
uh marines
at the airport
facilitating the evacuation
of
thousands and they're still there
facilitating the evacuation of just
thousands of afghan civilians
why
while there are still
hundreds and hundreds of americans
trapped behind enemy lines
and they're at the airport facilitating
this evacuation of just masses and
masses of of afghans
now we've been told that oh well the the
afghans were evacuating they're
interpreters are there people that
worked with our military we owe it to
them really all all of those masses of
people at the airport they're all
interpreters they all work now these are
just
people in afghanistan who showed up the
airport because they want to leave
understandably they want to leave
there's no way to know really who they
are or whether they worked with us or
not
it is a mob of people
who want to get out
again understandably
but what is not understandable is why
our guys are there dealing with that
the first objective should be
get americans out
first thing you
do
and then any afghans that we act that
actually worked with us if we made a
deal with them and said we're gonna get
you out then we should follow through on
that deal
and then after that you know what we do
we
leave it's not our job to evacuate half
of the country of afghanistan from the
country
but joe biden
standing in front of the people last
night
did not imbue anyone with a whole lot of
confidence um going forward i thought
we're to jump ahead a little bit because
i thought maybe the defining moment and
this will be
really the defining image of joe biden's
presidency and i said that when we were
sitting down watching the press
conference uh i said that at the time
this is the image right here
that will summarize his entire
presidency we'll see it here he's going
back and forth with uh peter ducey and
at one point he becomes sort of
exasperated and he kind of
hunches down
and just just watch it here if you
didn't see it here it is
you know as well as i do
that a former president
made a deal with the taliban
that he would get all american forces
out of afghanistan by may 1.
in return the commitment was made and
that was a year before
in return he was given a commitment that
the taliban
would continue to attack
others but would not attack any american
forces
remember that
i'm being serious
no i'm asking you a question
because
before no no no wait a minute i'm asking
you a question is that is that accurate
the best you're not
what
do you think that people have an issue
with
pulling out of that by just the weight
you know i've actually seen people on uh
social media claiming trying to defend
what biden is doing there
he he's what he's actually doing is he's
sort of like just giving up
um
i've seen people on social media
claiming that he's in that this is that
he's praying this was a moment of him
praying for the lives lost in
afghanistan
uh no that's not what he's doing
he's frustrated and he's collapsing on
camera he's giving up
he can't do there's one reporter in that
room and it's only ever peter ducey he's
the only guy there's one reporter in
that room who will ask tough questions
and actually have follow-ups and demand
some kind of answers
and this frail old pathetic
nothing of a man who was a pathetic
nothing of a man before he became frail
and old by the way
can't handle it
uh but i think even so that's the
defining image
there's one other moment before that
that also really encapsulates his
presidency i think
uh when he first
began to take questions the way that he
phrased it was was interesting let's
watch that
thank you
may god bless you all may god protect
his troops and all those standing watch
for america
we have so much
to do
it's within our capacity to do it
we just have to remain steadfast
steadfast
we will complete our mission
and we will continue
after our troops are withdrawn
to find means by which we can find
any american
who wishes to get out of afghanistan
we will find them and we will get them
out
ladies and gentlemen he gave me a list
here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc
mumbling
stumbling around
semi-coherent
it was very disturbing even before that
in a speech because he's doing a lot of
the mumbling thing he can be he can
barely speak it's no exaggeration to say
and then there will be these moments of
lucidity where he starts
it's like it was it's the joe biden of
15 years ago so
lucid in comparison right relatively
speaking but he has these moments where
suddenly he's on the ball a little bit
more
and he's projecting his voice more and
then he kind of
goes back down again so the the lucidity
comes in waves
and the waves are farther and farther
apart and that is what happens with
dementia where when someone is losing
their mind and losing their mental
facilities
where it begins where they've got these
rare moments where they kind of lose
track of their thoughts and
they go blank for a minute and that was
joe biden like five years ago
and then um and then those moments come
closer and closer together
and until eventually get to the point
where the lucid moments are the ones
that are far apart
we're watching that happen so so many
americans have watched this happen with
their grandparents or their parents and
now we're watching it happen with the
present united states
a consequence of having a 78 year old
president as i have
said all along and then he then he says
we're we're gonna i was instructed to
call on well who's instructing you
you're the president
who's passing on these instructions
and that's distressing to here for two
reasons number one he's he's too out of
it
to realize that he shouldn't be saying
that out loud
and number two for the obvious reason
that that
there is something to be said out loud
and to begin with here that he is being
instructed to do things
and that's a word of warning that's a
caution for all of the people right now
who are saying joe biden has to resign
uh impeach biden was trending yesterday
on twitter
and i i get it on an emotional level
i think he is
absolutely unfit to be president and has
been from the beginning
i think he deserves to be impeached
uh it's not ever going to happen you you
need the democrats to go along with that
of course they're not going to do it
but
even in some fantasy scenario where joe
biden was kicked out of office
remember that joe biden is the puppet
one who is being instructed to do things
he he is the pup he's the weeknd at
bernie's
fleshy mannequin who's carted out there
to barely even speak in front of cameras
so if he's the puppet and you get rid of
him or he steps down or he
goes on to meet his maker as many people
this age
do as everyone this age that age
eventually does
then you're going to go from the puppet
to the people pulling the strings
so it's hard to see that as an
improvement
and that only speaks to how i guess it
speaks to how to how absolutely screwed
we actually are
i hate to say it
there's really no way out of this
you would need everybody in the white
house and uh to to resign
you need the whole system to
forfeit their power
which is not going to happen
it's always been the plan from the
beginning i don't think anyone ever
uh anyone behind the scenes ever
imagined that joe biden would actually
make it all four years
so this is
all according to plan
i thought this was also pretty uh
revealing
yesterday morning
yeah august 26th at a right right before
8 a.m
this was tweeted out by the sergeant
major of the army michael grinston i
think we have this tweet from him
um
right before the attack okay now in
fairness this was this was before the
attack
like an hour before
here's where the sergeant major of the
army michael grinstein tweeted he said
diversity is a number do you have people
that don't look or think like you in the
room inclusion is listening and valuing
those people
women hashtag women's equality day
reminds us we're smarter and more lethal
when we come together as an inclusive
cohesive team our values demand it so
this is what the army this is what the
top brass the people in charge of our
military were worried about yesterday
while terrorists were strapping suicide
vests onto their bodies and heading to
the airport to kill 13 uh of of our own
guys
that this is what they were focused on
is celebrating women's equality day
claiming that we're really you're we're
more lethal by being inclusive
with women in the army they make us more
lethal
now you want to claim that makes us a
more tolerant army then go ahead but the
the point of the army is not to be
tolerant
it is to not tolerate certain things
like our enemies who wish us harm
but now the claim is that actually we're
more we are more deadly and fierce
and formidable fighting force if we're
inclusive and tolerant we've got a lot
of estrogen pumping through the ranks
how so
show me the uh the science on that i'd
like to see some studies on that
that show that uh the fighting units
with women are more deadly
so that defies all common sense
and there's no evidence of that
whatsoever and no reason to think that
it's true
but this is what our military is focused
on
and that's one of the points that i was
making yesterday in the backstage and
i've been making now for the last couple
of weeks that i i don't think uh
the united states should be in the
business of building empires overseas or
nation-building or
pursuing
imperial ambitions
i don't think that the united states
should be doing that
um our founding fathers certainly never
imagined that for the united states
never wanted that
but
even if i could go along with that in
theory even if in theory i could agree
that there's
that it's a good idea
for us to become an empire and to expand
our reach across the globe
the problem is we're not operating in
theory we're operating in reality
and in reality the people who are
running the empire are these kinds of
people
and this is the influence that they're
extending across the globe
so if you like the idea of empire
building in theory
what i would say is take it out of
theory and put it in reality do you want
these people
to be the ones building the american
empire because they're the ones doing it
uh and speaking of these people who are
in charge of the american empire nancy
pelosi in the midst of the crisis in
afghanistan yesterday she got this was
after the attack she got in front of
cameras and uh and this is what she was
talking about
here we are 101 years later
women in positions of high
uh responsibility
but an attack
on the by the right to vote that is
happening in our country
a few days ago on tuesday in the house
of representatives under the leadership
of terry sewell a woman from selma
alabama we passed the john lewis voting
rights enhancement act
to offset the damage that the courts are
doing to the right to vote and in doing
so we also need the senate to pass it
and to pass h.r one which is legislation
to overturn the voter suppression laws
that are being enacted across the
country not only to suppress the vote
but to nullify the vote so we have
important work to do
we have important work to do
i when i saw that clip yesterday i
actually did kind of a double take
because she
i kind of
clued in when she said there was an
attack
on the right to vote
after the deadliest day after she knew
that we just suffered the deadliest day
in afghanistan for our military in a
decade and she's out there talking about
the entirely fictional
attack on the right to vote
again get rid of biden and these people
are still in charge
another word of warning again all right
uh moving on to a couple other things
you may you may be hearing that it's a
bloodbath down in florida people dying
of covid left and right
uh you've probably seen the headlines
like this one from miami herald this is
a headline it says florida coveted
update
901 added deaths largest single day
increase in pandemic history
um
the
covid panic porn pushers have been
having a field day with this the
deadliest day in history they're saying
which is which is
at first kind of surprising because you
think well really we're having the
deadliest day now
when you've got
millions and millions of people who
either are vaccinated or have natural
immunity now we have our deadliest day
but that's unexpected
that's why you always want to go and
actually read the article so here's what
if you read the article this is what it
says
miami herald remember they said
deadliest day is the most deaths added
in a single day in pandemic history
and it says florida on thursday reported
21
765 more cova 19 cases and 901 deaths to
these centers for disease control
prevention
all but two of the newly reported deaths
occurred after july 25th
with about 78 of those people dying in
the past two weeks the majority of
deaths happened during florida's latest
surge in covenanting cases fueled by the
delta variant oh okay well hold on a
second
so we're going back to july 25th
so allegedly this the deadliest day most
deaths added is how they put it
but these are all the deaths that are
being reported that have happened over
the course of uh of an entire month
and that becomes the deadliest day
now they'll get away with this because
they'll say that what we didn't say was
the deadliest day exactly we said it was
the most reported deaths in a day
which technically is true but what they
want you to take away from that headline
and what most people take from it
because they don't click on it is that
it's the deadliest day
i i would hope that everyone realizes
this by now really with anything with
the media but especially
uh when it comes to these sensational
claims about covid
you look you can't judge anything by
headlines
you always got to read into it
there's almost always more to the story
here's another headline this is from the
ap it says the supreme court's
conservative majority is allowing
evictions to resume across the united
states blocking the biden administration
from enforcing a temporary ban that was
put in place because of the chronovirus
pandemic the court's action late
thursday
ends protections for roughly three and a
half million people in the united states
who said they faced eviction in the next
two months the court said in an unsigned
opinion that the centers for disease
control prevention which reimposed the
moratorium on august 3 lacked the
authority to do so
under federal law without explicit
congressional authorization
the justices rejected the
administration's arguments in support of
the cdc's authority
the three liberal justices dissented
justice stephen breyer writing for the
three pointed to the increase in cover
19
caused by the delta variant as one of
the reasons the court should have left
the moratorium in place
he said the public interest strongly
favors respecting the cdc's judgment at
this moment when over 90 of counties are
experiencing high transmission rates
so you notice how the liberal justices
who want to affirm this authority by the
executive branch
to
wave their scepters
mightily and declare that nobody is
allowed to all landlords across the
nation aren't allowed to evict
delinquent tenants
but even the liberal justices who
support it they don't make any
constitutional argument for it
they're not attempting to claim that
this authority exists in the
constitution
they're saying instead that uh well it's
it's there's a pandemic right now and
it's it's the public interest we should
respect which this is the constitutional
argument that the liberal justices are
making that we should respect the cdc's
judgment
there is no constitutional argument at
all in fact corey bush
who she was the one the uh member of the
squad remember she set up her little
fake homeless encampment outside of the
capitol building staging an insurrection
of sorts
and she had all of her oreos and junk
food and everything and she was up
hanging out out there
and she eventually was one of them one
of the main ones that that bullied the
white house into extending the
moratorium before this decision was
decided she tweeted 11 million people
will face eviction if the supreme court
blocks the eviction moratorium extension
it's a simple choice uphold the
moratorium or put the lives and
livelihoods and millions at risk
the american people are counting on
scotus to make the right decision
not simply false first of all that 11
million people are facing eviction
that assumes that all of the people who
have not been paying their rent
can't
and once this eviction the moratorium is
lifted
they're all going to be tossed out on
their butts
a certain portion of them will be and
justifiably so because they haven't been
paying the rent for a year
but
there's there's also going to be a
pretty large number of people who can
pay it but they're just not because they
don't have to
that's part of human nature
when you don't you don't force people to
fulfill their obligations there's a
certain portion of them who won't
unless you make them
but even if that was true
once again here there is no she doesn't
try to say
that the executive branch or the cdc had
this constitutional authority
instead it's an emotional argument it's
putting lives at risk
it has nothing to do with anything
actually
the only question is whether the cdc had
this constitutional authority to do what
they did and clearly they did all right
let's move now to reading the youtube
comments
this is from kunal who says matt is
harsh on politicians all the time but
he's never commented and commented on
male politicians looks so yes this was
sexist talking about my comments about
uh christine gnome well that's
not true at all just the other week i i
said that de blasio
the mayor of new york looks like the
love child of rex ryan and gumby so
which he does
i make fun of the looks of politicians
male and female all the time give me
some credit
here
um yo mama's boo says matt is low b low
key becoming as popular a conservative
voice as candace owens whenever he moves
people on both the left and right pay
attention even carrie underwood well i
appreciate that but please don't use the
phrase low key
uh you're too old for that
yo mama's boo i don't know how old you
are but i'm assuming because everybody
is but thank you and also you're banned
from the show
um jerry says matt what i love about you
most is you stick to your personal
beliefs no matter what criticism you
endure you're a good man and as a woman
i find you a very desirable type of man
that we need more of i'm just going to
read all these comments that are
complimenting me
um
schatzy says hot privilege is a
double-edged sword there are pitfalls to
being more attractive than a lot of
other women but it isn't misogyny to
point out that appearance may get you
more attention uh yeah i mean look as
someone who admittedly i experience hot
privilege myself that that is a
privilege
that i will admit to
and uh but it is it is kind of
as you point out
it's a blessing and a curse
i find my own beauty to be a both a
blessing and a curse
because on one hand uh i am
strikingly handsome on the other hand
people often don't treat me the same as
other people
and i know that i make others feel bad
when they
set their eyes upon me so
i think you're right about that
um and let's see
just another conservative says today my
identity has changed i am now a
non-binary slug that is attracted to
trans women who identify as fish again
thank you for your tolerance uh and
thank you for for coming out and
speaking your truth and living your
truth and i applaud you for that and i
find it quite
quite impressive and inspirational as
well
um
and dan vasquez says matt just own your
misogyny and be proud of being called
that the people who hate you are still
going to call you misogynist no matter
what just say okay and
they won't be able to use that against
you again
yeah i mean i don't care at all about
about being being labeled that
or about being labeled anything else
especially by people who reflexively
label you in lieu of making actual
arguments
but i'm also not going to as you say own
my misogyny because i'm not
in fact a misogynist so it would be
factually untrue i'm not going to agree
to something that's factually untrue
misogyny is the hatred of women
okay
and i don't hate women at all i love
women i think women are great
um i love women as women meaning i
appreciate the unique things that women
bring to the table in society
the people trying to erase women
literally erase them
they're the misogynists
they hate women
now
i kind of hate
what i'm saying right now because i'm
doing the uh
the dems are the real misogynists
and and i don't like that as i've said
many times the dems are the real racists
or dems of the real transphobes and i'm
kind of doing that here i realize that
but in this case they actually are
they they really are massages they
really do hate women
and they want to get rid of women as a
category
and i think that's an important point
i wouldn't necessarily say all of this
in response to being labeled that way
because i think that you're right that
dismissiveness
is the correct approach but between you
and me
this is the truth for the record thank
god folks it's time for your daily wire
promos you know as the legacy media
continues to spin the news our newest
podcast morning wire continues topping
the apple and spotify charts and we're
continuing our commitment to bring you
the news without a hidden agenda it's
the only daily podcast that values your
time and the truth uh
i mean i i'm a daily podcast and i value
the truth i don't really value your time
that's why i've drawn on and on so
actually i guess this is true and while
we're working overtime to bring you the
news you need to know we need your help
to keep the facts trending towards
number one so subscribe and start
listening now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and leave a five star review if
you like what you hear
you know i feel like the daily wire
promos for other shows shouldn't insult
the shows that are giving the promos
okay because you're claiming that i
don't value time and truth which i just
reject even if it's true uh also if you
want the news that other outlets won't
cover then the daily wires readers pass
is perfect for you for just four dollars
a month uh you'll unlock exclusive
access to editorial content that you
won't get anywhere else and right now
get a free four-week trial when you sign
up at dailywire.com subscribe but hurry
because this deal won't last forever you
get all kinds of uh op-eds and and
editorials and insights and analysis
from a lot of great writers including
ben shapiro kenneth owens even myself on
occasion all of this can be just yours
for just four dollars a month and if you
act fast you get your free four-week
trial at dailywire.com subscribe it's a
good deal and it's also never been a
better time to take it so what are you
waiting for get informed get a reader's
pass today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so today for our daily cancellation we
turn to transgender singer mila jam mila
jam has recorded an updated and revamped
version of the well-known song it's
reigning men by the weather girls
now the original is certainly no classic
not exactly an artistic high point for
western civilization though compared to
much of what came after and some of what
came before it may be higher up on the
scale than we would like to think but in
any case it's a dumb song it's a bad
song but it's it's kitschy and uh it has
character at least it's become iconic in
its own way thanks mainly to its use and
comedy montages and so forth another
quick side note here since we're on the
subject i discovered only just this
morning when i was researching the
background of its reigning men
because this is the kind of thing my job
entails so that i could give you all of
this unnecessary information i
discovered that one of the women in the
weather girls group
is named martha walsh
there's no relation as far as i know
though if there was i would certainly be
proud to call her kin
but we probably spent more time talking
about its reigning men than is necessary
mostly because no amount of time was
necessary at all and it's probably also
not necessary to play the remix for you
but i'm going to do it anyway because
there are a few salient points to be
made about it
in mila jam's new and inclusive version
for 2021 all references to men have been
removed which means the entire point of
the song has been removed there are also
no references to women
this song which is originally about sex
has been rendered sexless as mila jam
sings not about women or men but about
them
here's a small taste of it's reigning
theme
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna start
[Music]
raining hallelujah
[Music]
well
so there's that
i'm sure you're glad that you were able
to see that
and i'm glad you were too because if if
you can get past just how terrible the
song is and everything else about it i
think it does provide some very useful
if still grotesque and disturbing
insight into our current
cultural condition i mean think about
the chorus
it's raining them the original song has
heterosexual women singing about their
desire for men men are a particular and
definable group which uh with particular
definable features
which heterosexual women find appealing
but what are them i mean who are them
this is a vague and undefinable group
with no particular characteristics and
features are we supposed to imagine that
there are people who get all hot and
bothered and turned on by the thought of
them the thought of just people in
general with no other specifications
does anybody walk into a room filled
with people with thems
and feel attracted to everyone
regardless of their physical attributes
has anybody ever walked into like the
dmv and said hallelujah it's raining
people in here look at all these dems
i doubt that very many people work that
way but that is indeed how the left
thinks it should work and how we should
work
they wish to usher in a kind of sexless
ambiguous utopia where nobody is anyone
and there is no real sexual attraction
because sexual features are irrelevant
or erased and that's what this move to
non-binary is all about a
self-identification which means nothing
is inherently nonsensical but is also
increasingly popular especially among
younger people non-binary is not an
identity it's an anti-identity
it is the rejection of all that is
specific and particular and unique about
you
you become a them which is to say that
you become really nothing and no one
another good example of this
is is this here here's a high school
teacher in a recent viral video
coming out as non-binary to his students
watch
i'm about to come out to all my students
[Music]
so i have a quick announcement for
everybody can everybody look up from
their phones my class is important
please hello i'm waiting you guys look
at me
so i usually go by mr johnson but i
would like to be called zoa now my name
is zoa and i'm non-binary so you can
call me mr zoa you can call me miss zoa
you can call me mixoa that's mx period
and i go by all pronouns that's it
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks guys uh that's it
oh thank you
if you guys if anybody has any questions
you can ask me at the end of class
oh
bravo sir so so much not sir i apologize
uh
sir
sir and and ladies and gentlemen bravo
um that's uh to
to say to jump on this trend and to say
this thing that is sure to bring you
applause is just it's so courageous
really
now it's obviously bizarre and wildly
inappropriate for a high school teacher
to be talking to his students about this
at all
and this is just as obviously someone
who is not mentally fit to be a teacher
at all then again if we disqualify
teachers on that basis we'd be left with
only about 12 or 13 of them in the
entire country but either way
think about what he's saying
he is a he and a she and a mister
enemies
they and of them
he encompasses all identities he is all
things he is everything to everyone
now this is narcissistic to a literally
insane degree but it's a narcissism
and obsession with the self which erases
the self
he is so focused on himself so in love
with himself that he has obliterated
himself
he has collapsed into himself and become
a sort of ghost or phantom undefinable
identity-less
at least he wants to be undefinable and
identity-less
and yet he doesn't want to be that
either at the same time because you'll
notice something else
how the people who want to reject the
gender binary and remove themselves from
this thing which nobody can really
remove themselves from
they're reluctant to take it all the way
right
most of the time
because if you're a person who's neither
male nor female even though that isn't
possible and nobody fits into that
category or ever will i mean the
appropriate response when someone says
to you oh i'm non-binary the appropriate
response is no you're not
but if it was possible to be that
and that's the category to which you
belonged
that in fact your correct pronoun would
be not he or she or they are them but it
not they because they is plural and
you're just one person not he or she
because he or she denotes male or female
and you say that you're neither so it
would be the correct pronoun
and now think about what if my dreams
ever do come true and space aliens land
on this planet and they walk off their
spaceships and they appear to not have
any recognizable sex
well we would call them it wouldn't we
if we were talking about an individual
one of these creatures we would point
and say stuff like wow look at it
and well i hope it doesn't use that
laser gun on us and so on
but even most supposedly non-binary
people don't want to be called it
because it is dehumanizing
it makes you sound like you're not a
person but some sort of bizarre creature
some kind of swamp thing emerging from
the muck
you want to be a human and i don't blame
you
but the problem is that humans are males
or females
that's part of the human deal
you can't escape it you never will
and you shouldn't try
because to escape it is not to expand
your identity
but to lose it completely
and that's why the person who saying
that it's raining themselves is canceled
another one where it took us a while to
get back around to it but
they're not going to escape it they are
canceled for that and we will leave it
there for the day and the week hope you
have a great weekend talk to you on
monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin